il faut tenir compte de la de cette
représentation revanchiste de la chine
après tout elle a sa propre légitimité
conteste pas les traités inégaux ont
bien existé les occidentaux et les
russes ont bien humilié les chinois au
deuxième
au 19e et au début du 20e siècle je ne
nie pas mais ce qui n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une cette
représentation en schiste de devoir
redevenir gd bien redevenir ce que les
chinois considèrent comme ils y ont été
la première puissance du monde pendant
des siècles et des siècles et qui t'a
j'allais dire quitte à tout balayer tout
écrasé alors là pour le coup sans valeur
universelle c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et vous apprécierez mon sens de la
litote concernant notamment l'afrique et
bien je pense que de ce point de vue là
la chine doit être contenue et s'il faut
la contenir
avec une alliance plus forte amitié ou
une alliance plus forte
j'emploie le terme à escient d'alliance
de ce point de vue là avec la russie je
ne suis absolument pas compte dans la
mesure même où nous ne sommes pas les
seuls nous autres français et européens
à être menacée par ces nouveaux
l'impérialisme chinois mais la réussite
est aussi vous savez quand en sibérie
orientale
vous avez 5 6 millions de russes il ya
déjà beaucoup plus de chinois localement
et la russie est très notamment monsieur
poutine est extrêmement vigilant et très
moins attentifs à la montée en puissance
de la chine dans ce secteur un oublie
trop souvent que la réussite est
également une puissance asiatique pour
moi aujourd'hui le défi il est européen
merci entre guillemets je le dis un peu
par boutade à monsieur trump mais
j'espère que dans un mois il ne sera
plus président des états unis
j'ai merci à monsieur temps il donnait
avoir mis devant un véritable défi je
pense que l'europe comme l'a dit jean
yves le drian dans le monde daté du 20
avril si ma mémoire est bonne
l'europe doit être géopolitique en fin
de citation je le cite une part d'autre
part il faut que nous nous rapprochions
de la russie pas n'importe quelles
conditions notamment face aux périls
comme un chinois
et puis que nous jouions encore une fois
ce que nous avons c'est à dire des
valeurs et bien évidemment l'intérêt
national aux six agents n'en disconvient
pas du tout et nous avons encore nous
avons les moyens
une puissance moyenne pour défendre nos
intérêts et ceux de nos alliés et il
faut la jouer est rare en défense ça
s'assume
[Musique]